i've already
taken cheeseburger and chicken burger
and french fries
and vader's coke
[Music]
double cheeseburger
thanks god the same one the same
[Applause]
this new chain is a replacing mcdonald's
which is one of the most high profile
brands to leave russia after the russian
invasion of ukraine
here you can see the menu
okay breakfast
i think it's like the same
[Music]
opening of the first mcdonald's in 1990
was still when the soviet union was
intact it was very symbolic it was seen
as russia's opening to the west people
enjoyed mcdonald's there was something
that they could count on on long road
trips they knew what the quality is
going to be they knew it's going to be
clean the standards are there
and they could count on
you know what they were going to eat
every member in my family has a favorite
food that my mom loves
caesar all my grandma likes potato
veggies
and i can say that i'm really big fan of
the old mcdonald's
[Music]
so
politicians in russia are positioning
this reopening as a way to show that
russia can do well you know despite all
the sanctions and the boycotts by
corporations
it's kind of an easy
case that won't prove much sure they
will be able to make burgers but will
they be able to make cars will they be
able to make airplanes
[Music]
what happens next is unclear mcdonald's
hasn't commented on that mcdonald's
can bid on the deal on the franchise
again in the future we don't know
whether it does so or and under what
circumstances